bonjour bienvenue à tous c'est l'heure
de par le manque d'eau va refaire
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
au 45 minutes avec à mes côtés kathia
gilder bonjour week-end et dans
l'actualité cette semaine la majorité
reste étroite
mais ça passe l'ensemble du projet de
budget pour 2015 a été votée à
l'assemblée nationale votée mais de
justesse 37 députés de gauche se sont
abstenus
à présent c'est le sénat de droite qui
s'empare du texte
françois hollande rattrapé par la
primaire quelques voix au ps avait déjà
réclamé l'organisation d'un vote pour
désigner le candidat de 2017 pour la
première fois c'est un membre du
gouvernement qui met les pieds dans le
plat
thierry mandon il estime que les
primaires sont indispensables et c'est
dans ce contexte que les sénateurs se
sont penchés cette semaine sur cette
question faut-il réinstaurer le
septennat pour le président de la
république 7 ans non renouvelable
proposition de loi défendue par les
radicaux de gauche mais rejeté en séance
par le sénat
et pour commenter cette semaine très
politique notre invité et pierre laurent
bonjour aux gens sénateur de paris
secrétaire nationale du parti communiste
et président du parti de la gauche
européenne avant de commenter
l'actualité
je vous propose d'écouter ce que pensent
de vous dans les couloirs du sénat et de
l'assemblée certains parlementaires la
gauche divisée ne peut rien
seule la gauche rassemblée peu et ça je
sais que nous
beaucoup de choses à faire ensemble
après il faut qu'on est à écouter ce que
lille partie commises dans la somme de
critiques qui font la politique actuelle
du gouvernement que nous pouvons
partager
je trouve qu'il a un paradoxe c'est à
dire qu'il est dogmatique et en même
temps ouvert attaché à l'union à l'unité
de la gauche je pense son point fort je
pense et sa persévérance sa constance et
sa sincérité
pierre laurent c'est un homme
d'engagement que j'ai d'abord connu pour
son travail au sein de ge en à
l'humanité donc j'ai pu apprécier ses
grandes qualités à la fois découdre mais
aussi de promotion de combat qui me sont
chers je vais pas développer ici
oui c'est un homme d'engagement un homme
disponible
disponible aussi pour éventuellement
discuter avec les frondeurs avec les
verts pour faire des alliances
éventuellement ouais je suis
effectivement disponible pour tous qui
permettra de sortir le pays par le haut
de la crise actuelle et sortir des
politiques d'austérité et je mène
activement c'est vrai le débat avec
toutes les forces de gauche pour ça
parce que je pense que la politique
gouvernementale actuelle mène le pays
dans le mur et mène la gauche dans le
mur donc je travaille pour ça est ce que
david assouline appel du dogmatisme
c'est tout simplement la fermeté sur des
principes moi j'ai j'ai des engagements
effectivement sont des engagements à
gauche
et quand je dis quelque chose sur le
terrain au moment d'aller discuter avec
les citoyens avec les électeurs je ne
fais pas autre chose quand je suis au
gouvernement si un jour j étais donc
voilà c'est tout simplement que le
chemin que ça donc metting mais paradoxe
société aimerait vous voir peut-être un
peu plus dans les médias
c'était un petit manque de ce côté là je
vous savez je le connais puisque on est
on est on est dans le même
arrondissement à paris
donc on se côtoie moi je pense que je
répète ce que ce qui fait la qualité des
communistes c'est justement là leur
détermination à ne pas transiger sur un
certain nombre de principes dont
l'intérêt populaire
allez va passer au reste de l'actualité
de toute la semaine on va commencer par
le lundi on va revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé ce week-end et les réactions sont
nombreuses quant une salle crie
abrogation et bien candidat à la
présidence de l'ump répond ça coûte pas
plus cher
c'était devant les militants du mariage
pour tous nicolas sarkozy espérait
clarifier sa position et en lâchant le
mot abrogation du bout des lèvres sa
déclaration est bien là enflammé le
débat je vous propose de réécouter ce
que disait nicolas sarkozy à la tribune
par fait pas fait
sans nommer les temps y compris en temps
dit quand on dit qu'il serait très
écrite de fond en comble si vous
préférez qu'on dise qu'on doit l'abroger
pour en faire une autre en français ça
veut dire la même chose mais ça aboutit
au même résultat
nova si ça vous fait plaisir france
quand ça coûte pas très cher
question d'abord de forme et de fond sur
la forme est il possible comme ça que ce
n'est sécurisé par la foule et d'aller
plus loin que ce qu'on avait imaginé
fait peut-être qu'on s'aperçoit la
faveur de sa que c'est pas si nouveau
que cela chez nicolas sarkozy qui est
beaucoup qui est très préoccupée parfois
un peu trop de sa popularité qui
s'occupe pas assez du fond des choses et
du fond des problèmes des français
deuxièmement il n'a pas seulement 10 à
ce qui est grave dans ce qu'il a dit
c'est qu'ensuite emporté si je puis dire
dans son élan il a parlé de faire deux
mariages un mariage pour les homosexuels
et un mariage pour les hétérosexuels ce
qui est parfaitement scandaleux en soi
veut dire les droits skis et ski est
anticonstitutionnelle de toute façon à
mais c'est une logique de de loi séparé
ou de développement séparé qui est
parfaitement scandaleuse et
discriminatoire donc il sait plus ce que
laissait aller sur ce sujet et par
ailleurs c'est quand même assez étonnant
de voir une partie de la droite
française se radicaliser de cette
manière pour certains d'entre eux au nom
de l'église catholique aux observe moi
qui fais un observateur attentif que
même le pape a décidé d'ouvrir le débat
au moins sur cette question donc ce sont
des gens qui sont totalement archaïque
contrôle mans un contretemps qui ne sont
pas qui n'écoute pas ce que dit la
société française parce que même aux
plus hauts du mouvement pour le mariage
pour tous dans toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion
la société française a continué à dire
qu'elles étaient majoritairement
favorables au mariage pour les
homosexuels
en fait au mariage pour tous c'est à
dire à la possibilité pour chacun
regardons la voir ses revenus
2010c'est nous croyez vraiment qu'ils
pourront engranger peut-être des malades
défilent parce qu'on voit bien que c'est
c'est des gens qui sont animés par la
revanche mais je pense que la société
française dans sa très grande majorité
s'opposera à cette régression
ah je vous parle est un petit peu du
sénat ce lundi mais nationale a décidé
de prendre l'air gérard larcher il avait
promis pendant sa campagne pour la
présidence du sénat la haute assemblée
s'est délocalisée à chartres toute la
journée
la commission des lois a siégé elle a
réalisé des auditions préparer le texte
sur les compétences des collectivités
territoriales bilan de cette opération
va l'écouter avec le président du sénat
gérard larcher et volonté c'était d'être
au plus proche des acteurs du terrain
que ce soit les élus que ce soit les
forces économiques et et demain sans
doute les citoyens pour que nous
puissions échanger construire la loi
j'allais dire pas simplement comme des
techniciens de la loi mais comme ceux
qui sont tout le territoire le terrain
ou alors cette opération selon vous
senna hors les murs comme le président
je sais qu'un con con chercheur soient à
rapprocher le sénat des territoires je
suis d'accord mais le problème c'est que
si on s'en tient à des gadgets alors que
les lois que nous que que vote
l'actuelle majorité et avec parfois le
soutien de la droite
ce soit des lois qu'ils fassent
exactement contraire par exemple sur la
réforme territoriale c'est à dire on est
en train de s'éloigner mais le
s'éloigner des territoires et prennent
un jour faire des gadgets et des coups
de com mais ça ne change rien aux cas le
pays
oui le pays a besoin qu'on se rapproche
de lui mais à travers des lois qui
répondent à ces à l'envié et gère la
chaîne va beaucoup plus loin ce qu'il
veut réformer le sénat vous savez il a
décidé par exemple ça devrait en tout
cas un décider prochainement de moduler
les financièrement et de sanctionner
financièrement les élus qui ne seraient
pas suffisamment présents dans
l'hémicycle
l'absentéisme ou le présentéisme comme
il a appelé ça mais ce n'est pas très
très fort c'est même moi je pense
qu'effectivement quand on est élu on
doit assumer son mandat et de présent
commission être présent dans l'essai en
ce qui concerne les textes sur lesquels
nous travaillons et je voudrais quand
même dire que l'écrasante majorité des
parlementaires même quand je ne suis pas
d'accord avec eux sur le fond font ce
travail il ya un énorme travail
ils mériteraient d'être mis en valeur et
peut-être parfois davantage écoutés
parce que dans les commissions du sénat
on travaille avec beaucoup de débats
politiques et donc on est on est on peut
mais après qu'on prenne des mesures qui
permettent de lutter contre
l'absentéisme systématique moi ça ne me
choque pas aux soins mais il faut il je
veux dire arrêtons aussi de nourrir un
climat anti élus antiparlementaire là où
en vérité ce qui ce qui crée du divorce
avec le pays c'est le contenu les
politiques et on essaye de se défausser
de ce débat de fond pour nourrir un
climat que moi je trouve par certains
côté inquiétant qu'en juin grand journal
hier quitterait pour dénoncer ce qu'ils
appellent le coût des élections même pas
des élus maintenant on met en cause le
coût des élections ça devient trop cher
d'envoyer les professions de foi ça
devient trop cher de mener campagne
bon il ya des parties drôle l'ump qui a
montré qu' il était capable d'être hors
la loi sur les causes des élus dépenses
pour les quarts contre on a besoin de
dépenser de l'argent pour faire vivre la
démocratie mais moi je suis out cher en
ce moment mais ça nous coûte pas cher
écoutez quand on dépense plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros c'est
sabine organisé journal et pour
organiser des élections nationales où on
veut faire participer réellement les
citoyens tout vous savez tous les élus
locaux qui organise des consultations
dans leur territoire qui essaye de
travailler avec leurs élus de mettre en
place des conseils participatifs sable
que effectivement il faut dépenser un
peu d'argent pour permettre l'exercice
de la démocratie y en a c'est pas de
l'argent gâché ma pas tant que ça de
l'argent non plus en tout cas dans les
caisses de l'état mardi le gros budget
de la semaine est en discussion à
l'assemblée
en discussions ont finalement voté avec
37 abstentions côté socialiste le
secrétaire d'état au budget s'est réjoui
d'un vote sans guérilla parlementaire
françois moulin pour 266 contre 247
l'assemblée nationale a adopté voilà un
vote presque identique à celui d'il ya
un mois à deux voix près de voix en plus
contre le projet de loi de finances 2015
celle de deux socialistes qui se sont
trompé de bouton
à part cet incident le gouvernement se
félicite de voir le texte adopté dans ce
projet de loi de finances qui vient
d'être adoptée il faut pas oublier qu'il
y à une réduction de l'impôt sur le
revenu de plus de 3 milliards d'euros
pour neuf millions de foyers fiscaux
français en ont tendance à penser que
parce que la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public augmente de 3 euros
ça vient masquer cette ce mouvement très
forte diminution de l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est le fait marquant de ce
projet de loi de finances reste que 37
députés socialistes se sont abstenus
dont deux ex ministres
ils étaient 39 le mois dernier lors du
vote du volet recettes du projet de loi
les frondeurs reste mobilisée malgré
tout on est là pour éclairer
gouvernement est allé dire aux prisons
de la république au gouvernement écoute
et une peut-être temps qu'on réfléchisse
à faire un peu autrement
et donc voilà on vous propose des
solutions parce que notre abstention
elle sait qu'un vote mais avant il ya
tous les amendements qu'on a présenté
qui sont des amendements qui visent à
rééquilibrer la politique entre l'effort
la politique en direction de ce qu'on
appelle de l'offre et puisque nous la
pratiquons intéressante qu'on appelle la
demande qui comporte l'investissement
des entreprises comme le mois dernier
les écologistes se sont abstenus en
majorité une fois de plus c'est le
soutien déterminant des radicaux de
gauche qui a fait la différence
le front de gauche tout comme l'ump ont
voté contre
très remonté contre ce budget 2015 la
peau sur le revenu dont on y va baisser
le volume collecté de l'impôt sur le
revenu il est plus important en 2015
en 2014 je veux bien qu'ils aient une
baisse historique des des prélèvements
obligatoires mais c'est la toute petite
histoire c'est pas du tout la grande
histoire
donc on voit bien que c'est pas à la
hauteur c'est le budget du chômage fort
et c'est le budget de la croissance
faible pour pas s'en satisfaire
le texte voté sera à présent examinée à
partir de jeudi au sénat où il devrait
être largement détricoté avant de
revenir en seconde lecture à l'assemblée
qui aura le dernier mot
voilà alors ce budget 2015 est devant
vous sénateur est ce que vous allez
apporter des amendements
bien sûr nous allons faire notre travail
nous allons nous allons essayer
d'amender ce budget singulièrement en
matière de fiscalité puisqu'on va
démarrer par 10 par discuter de ça or le
problème de ce budget c'est qu'il ne va
pas chercher les recettes fiscales là où
ils devraient aller les chercher et il
multiplie les cadeaux fiscaux sans
aucune utilité pour le pays avec une
addition extrêmement extrêmement salée
et je crains contrairement à ce qui
vient d'être dit dans le reportage que
la droite sénatoriale ne détricote pas
le budget mais quand finalement elle en
rajoute dans la direction prise elle en
rajoute dans le mauvais sens dans la
direction prise et vous verrez vous
verrez que la droite sénatoriale va
adopter le budget amendé par elle ça
sera un budget qui ira dans la même
direction et qui sera encore pire parce
que ils vont en rajouter en matière
d'exonération est là où au contraire il
faudrait aller chercher à aller chercher
de l'argent tout autrement dans les
chais ceux qui ont nom à la fois le
capital et les plus fortunés qui ne
payent pas assez et pendant que vous
débattre et bruxelles rendra sa décision
notamment à partir de lundi est ce que
vous craignez les foudres de presse m
mais bruxelles on sait très bien ce que
va dire bruxelles bruxelles va dire il
faut continuer à tailler dans les
dépenses publiques
c'est ce qui est en train d'enfoncer
pour les pays européens dans le chômage
jusqu'à quand on va écouter les
directives de bruxelles certains excuses
mais mais bien sûr qu'il faut affronter
bruxelles nous sommes un grand pays
européen
et il faut dire maintenant nous ne
pouvons pas aller dans la direction vous
nous proposez puisqu'elle produit les
résultats inverses de ce que vous
prétendez faire avec ces budgets là
parce que les budgets d'austérité qu'un
point
la vraie question c'est est ce qu'on
mène ce bras de fer contre bruxelles
est-ce que vous ne la verrez ce que vous
dites à françois hollande aujourd'hui
non là résistaient russell dans la grèce
qui est un cas c est ce qu on réduit le
chômage
est-ce qu'on réduit le chômage est-ce
qu'on va réduire le chômage en
matraquant les plus modestes et ont
continué à exonérer le capital de toute
contribution est ce qu'on va continuer à
réduire le chômage en permettant à des
grandes multinationales de ne pas payer
d'impôts comme ça à l'air d'être révélée
parce qu'il y avait un accord secret
entre juncker qui est le président de la
commission européenne quand il dirigeait
le gouvernement de luxembourg et 348
canal alors c'est ces gens là qui vont
nous donner des leçons alors budgétaire
et non les chiffres comme des moutons
pour l'instant pour l'instant il n'est
pas question de ça puisque la discussion
se poursuit au parlement est une autre
question qui ressurgissent aussi à
l'occasion ce budget c'est la question
des 35 heures est ce que vous êtes prêt
à un débat sans tabou sur les 35 heures
rouvert par donc emmanuel macron oui
mais bien sûr puisque emmanuel macron
lui va essayer d'appliquer dans sa loi
avec elle toutes les recommandations du
medef dont celle là fait partie et bien
quand l'allemagne va creuser ça va très
bien paquet les stades
non mais donc 35 ans chantera bien
aujourd'hui même on a fait les 35 heures
qui était pour les salariés qui en ont
bénéficié une bonne chose sauf que déjà
il y avait un problème et qui n'a fait
que s'aggraver
c'est qu'on n'a pas créer les emplois
nécessaires qu'il fallait créer pour
permettre le partage du travail et on a
continué à tirer les salaires vers le
bas
et qu'est ce que propose macro il
propose d'aller encore plus loin dans
cette déréglementation et macro il va
nous proposer pas seulement la remise en
cause des 35 heures mais la
généralisation du travail du dimanche la
remise en cause de la médecine du
travail
la remise en cause des prud'hommes donc
en gros il nous propose la
déréglementation sociale à tous les
étages ne va pas y toucher à l'emploi ça
eh bien moi je dis non
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on nous
raconte plus ont des règlements que le
travail on le voit en france comme en
europe est bien plus le chômage et la
pauvreté augmente donc c'est vrai qu'on
veut toucher aux 35 heures sont à
nouveau
à détricotage surtout le son et sa
science de la nacre on qu'il est en
train de préparer c'est l'addition du
tout une série de déréglementation
sociale nouvelle voilà ce qu'est
l'essence de la loi absolue même combat
et le et le medef qu'est ce que va faire
le medef comme d'habitude va dire oui
tout ça c'est très bien mais y en a pas
assez
et ils vont continuer dans la surenchère
comme vient de le faire via gas gas avec
la suppression de l'sf et a juste envoyé
sur cette suppression de l'sf qu'est ce
que vous dites sont ici ça se passe mal
agatha jeu les visiteurs descendant la
rue de nous des sans voix si vous
descendez dans la rue on va faire une
contre semaine d'action et gels et j'ai
mis au défi le président du menez pierre
gattaz de faire un débat public avec moi
puisqu'il avait dit il avait dit mais
avant avant de revenir juste au débat
juste une chose il a dit un truc
incroyable moi je veux discuter de ça
avec lui
le président du medef il a dit la
fiscalité en france est inversé elle est
trop faible sur la consommation parce qu
on a une tva seulement à 20% il faudrait
l'augmenter et elle est très fort sur le
capital c'est exactement l'inversé
la première recette fiscale française
c'est la tva qui rapporte trois fois
plus que l'impôt sur le revenu parce que
l'impôt sur le revenu dans les rues
proches est un vrai gruyère et qui
rapporte six fois plus que l'impôt sur
les sociétés donc il dit un mensonge et
on continue d'écouter le président
tassos direct avec donc il faut une
confrontation directe et moi je lui
propose sur une chaîne de télévision il
a déjà accepté hier par tweet que cette
confrontation ait lieu dans les colonnes
de l'humanité
j'en suis ravi c'est un journal le monde
c'est un joli et mes chers mais moi je
propose qu'on coupe le débat dans la
presse écrite avec un débat sur une
chaîne si vous voulez si vous avez gagné
si vous êtes si vous êtes prêts à le
faire moi je sais j'y suis tout disposé
mais pour le moment il a l'air d'être un
peu hésitant sur l'animation puck lui
même un public de ce débat là mais
puisque lui même a dit puisque c'est
cette balle au bond que j'essaie d'y ya
trop pas assez politique qui qu'ils
veulent qu'ils encouragent du débat au
moins il a en face de lui un politique
qui a le courage du débat alors qu'ils
saisissent cette occasion de
débattent franchement on a fini de
sagatta je voudrais qu'on revient d'un
petit peu ce qui se passe au sénat et
quelques mois notamment sur le sénateur
serge dassault encore des
rebondissements dans leur quête de
soupçons d'achat de voile à corbeil
essonnes sur vos tablettes a entendu
début octobre par les juges leur
explique comment il a remis 53 millions
d'euros en liquide à l'ancien maire de
la ville on a très peu entendu la gauche
vous même peut-être sur ce dossier ça
fait la une d'un journal libération plus
que rien mais écoutez c'est parce que
c'est ça fait des années et des années
que nous dénonçons que nous dénonçons
ces pratiques nous les avons dénoncées
dans la ville de corbeil et ce qui est
pitoyable dans cette affaire ce qui est
pitoyable c'est que la justice ne
parviennent pas alors que manifestement
je veux dire il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
autant de fait à chaque fois révélé son
qui est des réalités derrière quand est
ce que la justice va avoir le courage de
s'attaquer à ces dossiers d'aller au
bout de ce manque de courage de la
justice sur la sphère d'assaut mais en
tout cas il faut lui donner les moyens
d'aller au bout c'est sûr que les
pressions sont considérables dès qu'on
s'attaque à des aléas des gens qui ont
des positions établies
voilà c'est plus difficile manifestement
donc je suis moi je crois qu'il faut il
faut aller au bout de ces dossiers non
moi je fais confiance à la justice mais
il faut l'encourager à aller aller au
bout de la route ces dossiers parce que
c'est insupportable au bout d'un set ce
sentiment d'impunité dans laquelle dans
laquelle certains sont parce qu'ils sont
franklin c'est pour cette raison on
parle d'un sénateur mais aussi un député
qui a fait son apparition à l'assemblée
une nouvelle apparition
thomas thévenoud qui a donc siéger en
commission
oui vous taper du poing sur la table il
est pourtant été vu donc en commission
réactions hostiles de plusieurs députés
dont olivier falorni qu'est ce que vous
dites ça vous indigne ça me choque
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dans la vie
c'est là aussi c'est pitoyable
ça veut dire que ces gens ont donc une
aucune des gens qui ont fraudé le fisc
et qui continue à siéger comme si de
rien n'était et qui prétend de faire la
loi est voté le budget parce que thomas
thévenoud il l'a voté le budget parmi
les quelques voix qui font la majorité
il ya thomas thévenoud lui paye pas ses
impôts mais
budget moi je trouve ça insupportable
bon donc effectivement le ce qui doit je
pense que dans sa circonscription
ces électeurs doivent le dire nous
devons être nombreux à le dire et après
je pense qu'il devrait démissionner
voilà parce que c'est là c'est ça la
morale publique tout simplement
alors va revenir un peu sur la politique
et ce qui s'est passé aussi également
cette semaine au sénat avec une
proposition a demandé par les membres
des partis radical quelques éléments
d'histoire pour revenir sur le septennat
c'est cette proposition qui a été
demandée par le groupe radical regarder
ce que jérôme bonnard a refait un petit
peu l'histoire et on va regarder ça
c'était en juin 2000 au sénat cette
réforme a été longuement mûrie
elle apparaît nécessaire pour donner une
nouvelle dynamique démocratique à nos
institutions
et puis elle est aujourd'hui enfin
possible il faut donc la faire soutenu
par la gauche le projet de loi visait à
réduire la durée du mandat présidentiel
à cinq ans adopté sans modification par
l'assemblée et le sénat la réforme
laisser la droite plus dubitative
jacques chirac favorable au projet
choisi le référendum pour le faire
adopter
à l'époque l'objectif était d'éviter de
nouvelles cohabitation en alignant la
durée du mandat présidentiel à celui du
mandat législatif
quatorze ans plus tard le sénateur
jacques mézard préconise un retour au
septennat à condition qu'il soit non
renouvelable le président du sénat y
voit des avantages cher mandat de sept
ans qui mettrait en quelque sorte le
président de la république à un niveau
plus arbitral - lié directement à la
politique du quotidien non renouvelables
aussi pour qu'il puisse avoir à conduire
les réformes sans avoir pour objectif de
se faire réélire
cinq ans après réfléchissons cinq ans
chez très court ce qui au final pourrait
renforcer le rôle du parlement au
détriment de celui du chef de l'état
reste que ce texte a peu de chances
d'être adoptée il a déjà été rejetée en
commission des lois au sénat vous
séduire elle est très insuffisante
aujourd'hui le quinquennat était une
très mauvaise idée
nous étions opposés au quinquennat à
l'époque c'était un concert de louanges
sur les bancs du parti socialiste et de
la droite
c'était une très mauvaise idée qui nous
a entraînés dans une spirale de
présidentialisation extrême du régime et
un amoindrissement progressif du rôle du
parlement et non à transformer les
élections législatives en une sorte
d'élection dans d'enregistrement
présidentielle eh bien c'était une très
mauvaise idée mais maintenant on ne va
pas corrigé sa part un retour en arrière
à mon avis ça il faut tout remettre à
plat
il faut une sixième république donc il
faut réécrire l'ensemble de la
constitution parce que derrière ce
problème là il ya le problème du pouvoir
présidentiel qui doit diminuer
on profite d'une revalorisation
parlementaire et il faut aussi repenser
tout le processus démocratique dans le
pays les élections
la réforme territoriale devrait faire
partie de cette réflexion
donc il faut tout repenser nous nous
sommes pour une sixième république bien
compris on a une autre question cette
semaine
faut-il des primaires l'idée ressurgit
aussi belle aura suffi d'une petite
phrase du secrétaire d'état thierry
bourdon pour mettre le feu aux poudres
c'est françois hollande devra t-il
passer par des primaires s'il souhaite
se représenter en 2017 la question est
posée et la gauche commence aussi à se
poser cette question françois goulard
non il ne s'agit pas d'une nouvelle
bourde d'un membre du gouvernement mais
bien d'une idée sérieuse que formule le
secrétaire d'état thierry mandon l'idée
d'une grande primaire à gauche avant
2017 la primaire pour moi elle est
indispensable parce que particulièrement
2010 est ce que vous ne réglez pas dans
une primaire
vous le retrouvez au premier tour de la
présidentielle donc je plaide pour la
primaire élargie le plus radicaux
écologistes et tous ceux qui voudront y
participer à cette primaire pourrait
participer
françois hollande lui même affirme le
secrétaire d'état jusqu'ici seule aile
gauche du ps réclamé l'organisation d'un
tel événement mais la proposition est
loin de susciter un fol enthousiasme
chez les écologistes
moi ce que je pense c'est que pourraient
soir un candidat de gauche au second
tour de la présidentielle fait faire une
politique de gauche maintenant
il faut un accord mais non mais c'est
bien sympa de se poser la question de la
primaire de la présidentielle
aujourd'hui on a huit millions de
pauvres et si on trouve les gens se
déplacent pour voter il faut peut-être
déjà changé leur vie quant au front de
gauche les communistes sont
historiquement opposés à participer à
une primaire ouverte
il ne resterait que les radicaux de
gauche indéfectible partenaires du
mandat de françois hollande et seul
parti convient aux primaires ouvertes de
2011 alors primaire ou pas à gauche on
en parle tout de suite c'est le zoom
nous accueillons thomas guénolé bonjour
je vous êtes politologue maître de
conférences à sciences po et vous
connaissez bien
cette question est ce que françois l'on
pourra échapper à des primaires s'il s'y
soumet ce serait une travers présent la
réplique
vous avez vu les statuts oui justement
c'est à dire que je voudrais a profité
de l'occasion pour lancer un appel à
tous les journalistes politiques de
france lisez les statuts du ps
lisez l'article 5 3 1 des statuts je ne
sais pas si on voit la caméra parce que
comme ça également tout le monde l'aura
vu d'accord alors que dit cet article
prétend je vais vous le dire pour être
sûr en substance le candidat à la
présidence de la république est désigné
au travers de primaire citoyenne ouverte
à l'ensemble des citoyens
adhérant aux valeurs de la république et
de la gauche est co-organisé par les
formations politiques de gauche qui
souhaitent y participer de roncq
donc c'est tout s'est terminé il ya donc
les radios il n'y a aucune exception
prévue
il n'y a pas d'exception n'y a pas et si
le président sortant et ps ont fait
autrement etc
on s'arrange avec les rênes il n'y a pas
d'exception alors il reste deux
possibilités la direction du ps est
serré par exemple de violé ses statuts
en ne faisant pas la primaire dans ce
cas de la nature dans ce cas là
n'importe quel candidat potentiel à la
primaire au hasard arnaud montebourg peu
épuisé les voies de recours internes
parce que c'est une association loi 1901
parties puissent saisir le tribunal
administratif et forcer la direction à
le faire la jurisprudence administrative
est très clair là-dessus et l'autre
possibilité c'est de modifier les
statuts pour faire sauter donc j'en
profite pour leur montrer l'article 5 3
mais dans ce cas-là ça suppose d'avoir
la majorité des adhérents qui vous
suivent en congrès
sauf que ce qu'ils veulent de martine
aubry à la place de françois hollande
votre et contre ceux qui veulent
d'arnaud montebourg à la place de
françois hollande veut très content et
même certains de ceux des adhérents qui
vous
le françois hollande mais qui sont
attachés au principe des primaires votre
et compte donc la majorité pour modifier
les statuts vous ne l'avez pas donc je
leur montre pour être sûr dit le 5 3 1
cette idée de primaire mais je pense que
la gauche moi je partage ce qu'a dit
emmanuelle cosse tout alors le à gauche
n'a pas un problème de primaire la
gauche un problème de choix politiques
et c'est ce débat là qu'il faut qu'on
vient d'avoir je rappelle quand même une
chose parce que c'est l'article en
question a été appliquée la dernière
fois par le parti socialiste donc la
situation très problématique dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons est le
résultat d'une primaire je rappelle que
dans cette primaire arnaud montebourg
par exemple qui vient d'être évoquée a
choisi entre les deux tours de s'allier
avec françois hollande par exemple aux
côtés de manuel valls
donc c'est pas forcément une primaire
qui va résoudre le problème qui est posé
à la gauche donc et en plus dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes qui
est une situation où justement il ya un
débat sur les institutions est ce qu'il
faut continuer et continuer en rajouter
dans la présidentialisation de la vie
politique alors que la question c'est
que le pays veut débattre de la
politique qui est menée des programmes
non mais écoutez une primaire vous savez
très bien comment ça se passe une
primaire elle focalise sur les
personnalités qui sont candidates
quoi qu'on quoi qu'on fasse elle efface
elle privilégie ce débat là on est façon
le débat de faux et moi je pense qu'il
ya mieux à faire par exemple gauche
front de gauche nous proposons à toutes
les forces de gauche de construire des
assises politiques des assises citoyenne
parce qu'il faut discuter des choix
politiques
si on repart dans une primaire sans
avoir eu ce débat sur les choix
politiques et le faire de manière claire
en faisant partager ce débat par les
citoyens en associant les citoyens ses
choix eh bien on reproduire à nous les
erreurs qui ont fait la gauche dans la
situation actuelle de phrases un la
primaire à mon avis ça permet de
débattre des idées on n'a jamais autant
débattu publiquement des idées au ps que
quand il eut la primaire de 2011
notamment entre arnaud montebourg et
manuel valls y avait des différences
énormes et ça s'est vu à l'antenne et 2
juste une deuxième phase oui ça
s'appelle l'union de la gauche et
l'autre question c'est pourquoi la
gauche radicale rockeuse radical par
rapport au ps qui elle-même estime juste
être la gauche normal pourquoi il
n'organise pas des primaires ouvertes
pour leur propre formation parce que si
vous n'avez pas un seul candidat de
toute la gauche qui est contre
l'austérité
vous n'avez aucune chance de passer à
table ronde a été capable de se mettre
d'accord sur un candidat commun là on
disait que c'était impossible
je rappelle que le parti communiste a
soutenu un candidat qui n'était pas un
candidat issu du parti communiste
l'année dernière pierre rigole-t-elle
tout simplement parce que nous avons su
intelligemment mené un débat politique
et adopté un programme qui s'appelait
l'humain avant qui est d'ailleurs si
vous le relise est extrêmement pertinent
dans la situation politique et je pense
que ça c'est plus porteur d'avenir qu'un
débat des primaires hypermédiatisé hyper
personnalisé et qui efface saison jeu là
est précisément la question c'est qu'il
faut que les citoyens se sont impliqués
dans le débat dans les choix politiques
et 16 de s'en remettre à des personnes
qui serait soit disant les sauveurs les
personnages rancourt et c'est parce que
toute l'asie tient boutique était à la
merci thomas galonnés d'avoir été sur le
plateau de parlement hebdo on enchaîne
avec jeudi un échange très cinglant dans
l'hémicycle entre un ministre et un
député
la représentation nationale était en
train d'examiner la nouvelle carte des
régions et soudain bernard cazeneuve a
pris la parole pour dire ses quatre
vérités à françois de rugy écoutez
monsieur de rugy est ce que vous
pourriez une minute
dès lors que ça me concerne enlevez la
haine que vous avez la commissure des
lèvres
vraiment je vous le demande je parle de
vous systématiquement lorsque je
m'exprime vous le prêter des intentions
que je n'ai pas je vous ai entendu sur
d'autres sujets proférer des attaques
que j'ai considéré comme indigne moi je
ne suis pas dans la haine monsieur de
rugy
ce n'est pas ma culture ce n'est pas ma
main non c'est vous qui l'êtes
et si vous voulez que je vous fasse la
liste les propos que vous avez tenus sur
mon compte qui relèvent de la
diffamation
au cours des dernières semaines je peux
les rappeler ici donc je n'ai aucune
leçon de dignité politique à recevoir de
vous mais c'est la réponse c'est ma
réponse parce que je n'ai vu dans vos
propos depuis des semaines que de la
haine et de l'insulté à la commissure
des lèvres
et pour ce qui me concerne ce ne sera
jamais mon approche ce ne sera jamais ma
culture ce ne sera jamais ma manière
d'être
parce que je considère que la vérité la
réflexion et le refus de l'abaissement
de la politique doivent conduire à
d'autres os portement et je vous le dis
en public parce que contrairement à vous
lorsque j'ai quelque chose à dire je
n'attends pas que la personne soit
absente pour le lui dire j'attends
qu'elle soit en face de moi
la haine aux commissures des lèvres le
mans est très fort ça vous choque cet
échange drame de quoi je voyais tout cet
échange vous choque surtout quand on
sait le sujet dont il est question qui
est la mort d'un jeune homme dans une
sirène quand on débat et singulièrement
quand on débat dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale d'une dune d'un
événement aussi tragique
on évite les polémiques de base et à la
34e minute à l'intérieur pardon au
travail qu'il ya de la haine contre le
ministre l'intérieur
mais moi je me suis je ne suis pas animé
par la haine j'ai des convictions et
parfois elles sont très radical à
l'égard de
de certains mais la haine n'est pas n'a
pas sa place à mesure on peut alors
cette passe d'armes a eu lieu pendant le
débat sur les régions ça finalement été
votée on aura 13 régions il peut y avoir
un échec lors de la commission mixte
paritaire entre l'assemblée et le sénat
pour se mettre d'accord finalement sur
cette région
c'est l'assemblée qui aura le dernier
mot que ce que vous en pensez où on
reste à 13 régions il vous plaît cette
carte
rien ne me plaît donc territoriale
actuelle parce que justement elle a été
menée au pas de charge en méprisant tout
ce que disaient les élus locaux et la
sphère de la carte des régions parmi
beaucoup d'autres choses dans la réforme
territoriale est symptomatique c'est à
dire quoi qui se passe au parlement de
toute façon ce qui a décidé ce qui a été
décidé un jour dans le bureau de
l'elysée fini par être le point
d'arrivée et tout ce qui se passe entre
temps c'est des péripéties mais qui sont
balayés à l'arrivée en france a lancé
or tout le monde sait que sur cette
question comme sur d'autres questions
beaucoup plus profonde que le périmètre
des régions il ya une énorme
contestation dans le pays
chez les citoyens chez les élus locaux
il ya également eu de concertation et de
donner les élections c'est demain la
sélection c'est demain alors quelle est
votre stratégie est ce que vous êtes
prêts à des alliances mais nous allons
carré mais comme d'habitude nous allons
aux élections avec un objectif c'est
conquérir avec les citoyens des
positions qui soit utile à faire avancer
des positions qui qui permettront
défendre leurs intérêts donc dans les
élections à venir nous nous voulons
faire élire des candidats de gauche
pas seulement communiste on est prêt à
discuter avec d'autres avec d'autres pas
seulement qu'ils défendront déposition
contre les politiques d'austérité
actuelle parce qu'elles ne sont pas
bonnes pour les populations locales qui
protégeront les services publics et les
politiques publiques
par exemple dans les départements on
joue très gros pour les gens c'est 72
milliards au total les départements de
dépenses sociales et publiques qui sont
principalement consacrée à l'action
sociale
donc ce sont des politiques de public de
solidarité dans la plupart des cas des
politiques d'équipement pu
licques et bien nous nous voulons
protéger ses politiques publiques parce
que si on ne se rend plus il y aura de
la privatisation ou simplement tous les
crs qui ne seront plus assurées par les
départements le trou par la
privatisation avec des inégalités
croissantes nous nous voulons pas de ça
donc nous voulons battre les candidats
de droite la droite et nous voulons et
nous voulons élire des candidats de
gauche qui expriment les positions dont
je viens de parler donc nous allons
discuter sur le terrain parce que ça se
discute dans les départements avec tous
ceux qui sont qui sont prêts à ça et
y'en a pas il ya évidemment les forces
du front gauche et les écologistes et
les socialistes qui sont prêts à
discuter de ça il ya aussi des citoyens
parce qu'on peut ne pas être engagé dans
un parti et on peut être candidat à une
élection
donc nous allons utiliser ces élections
pour construire des rassemblements dans
les territoires alors on va changer de
registre on va vous parler de l'homme de
l'année en tout cas celui qui a été
distingué par le magazine jq alain juppé
qui est dans le vent décidément elle
avait déjà fait la une des inrocks voilà
donc un autre magazine qui cède à la
jupe et magna c'est ce qu'on dit ça vous
étonne cette jupe et malia vous adhérez
pour moi je suis pas du tout contre elle
pas compter sur moi pour ça oui mais
c'est toujours d'aider des gens qui qui
se pose qui répondent à la place des
citoyens devront nous enferme dans des
scénarios les des scénarios catastrophe
alors on aurait le choix entre sarkozy
l'open et puis qui porte la politique
gouvernementale et on lui dit bas plutôt
que ce scénario catastrophe qui a
peut-être moins pire il ya juppé qui est
un homme généreux qui défendent qui
défend qui défend des programmes
extrêmement libéraux qui défont il veut
encore plus de suppression de dépenses
publiques qu'on en a aujourd'hui donc
comment voulez-vous que moi je me
reconnaissent là dedans évidemment moi
mon travail ça va être de faire émerger
dans ces échéances politiques
une candidature de gauche qui soit digne
de ce nom et qui ne peut pas être une
créature qui porte la gouvernement la
politique gouvernementale actuelle et je
vais pas me replier sur la jupe et
maliens comme si c'était un mois
vous composez une autre photo qui a fait
beaucoup parler offre cette fin de
semaine c'est le magazine people voici
qui la publie dans les jardins de
l'elysée on y découvre le président de
la république et sa compagne julie gayet
pas parler forcément de la vie privée
mais je voudrais surtout parler de
l'avis du président de la république des
photos prises comme ça de loin dans un
jardin des photos volées ça paie pas
quelque part en problème en relief la
sécurité du président
franchement je vais vous dire une chose
ça ne m'intéresse pas ça ne m'intéresse
absolument pas françois hollande fait ce
qu'il veut de sa vie privée car ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas pour moi un sujet un
sujet public donc cette question ne
m'intéresse pas et les couverture de
voici que des jolies ça ça les regarde
mais ça n'est pas un sujet ça dépend ce
sujet qui intéresse la politique
on va prendre un peu de recul père
laurent recul avec l'actualité politique
puisque c'est lors du plus de l'hebdo
astrid de vilaine vient d'arriver sur ce
plateau bonjour vous regardez tout sur
le web régulièrement chaque jour tout le
temps eh bien nous vous avez voulu
vérifier la réputation de notre invité
alors que trouve-t-on sur pierre laurent
sur internet et bien tapée et pierre
laurent dans un moteur de recherche et
vous trouverez des résultats assez
classique pour un politique une page
wikipédia concise sans vagues votre blog
plutôt design avec une belle photo de
vous en pied votre équipe y tenait
d'ailleurs cette photo elle est assez
original on dirait du andy warhol est-ce
que c'est fait exprès tout ça je sais
pas si c'est cette prétention mais à mes
yeux c'est plutôt c'est plutôt un
compliment si c'est le cas alors
certains nous ont dit que vous aviez un
petit peu de mal avec le costard cravate
obligatoire au sénat je fasse si vous
confirmez
et c'est vrai que la photo de vous
ouvrant un petit peu plus cool vous dit
manquer de temps pour écrire sur ce blog
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on est loin
des billets d'humeur de jeu
alors justement est-ce que la
comparaison avec jean luc mélenchon
tient aussi sur internet pour pierre
laurent clé oui elle tient et si on
regarde les chiffres et bien vous êtes
loin derrière lui évidemment jean luc
mélenchon c'est un petit peu la star du
front de gauche prenons facebook par
exemple vous êtes suivi par dix neuf
mille personnes c'est un bon score mais
évidemment lui il en a dix fois plus que
vous 195000 fans twitter même chose
quinze mille follower pour pierre
laurent
296 me pour jean luc mélenchon il faut
dire qu'il a été candidat à l'élection
présidentielle peut-être que ça vous a
grossi mais juste un mot sur le costard
cravate et actuellement c'est pas sympa
le la tenue dans laquelle je me sens le
plus à l'aise mais bon je respecte les
usages mais pour vous raconter une
anecdote quand quand je suis rentré au
sénat et dans une fête d'anniversaire
tous mes amis avaient tous moi mais tous
acheté une cravate c'est parce qu'il
savait parce qu'ils savaient que je n'en
avais pas en fait parce que avant de
devenir sénateur
il n'y avait pas dans les placards
beaucoup de travail mais ceci étant dit
j'ai 7 ans à la stricte
je respecte tout à fait cet usage
l'attitude de père laurent sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien au premier abord
on voit quelqu'un de très réfléchi très
sérieux presque un peu ennuyeux sur le
net
en tout cas il ne se passe pas grand
chose sur votre timeline c'est souvent
assez plat on ne se dit pas à un tweet
de pierre laurent quelle bombe at il
lâché
non mais quand on cherche bien dans les
archives de twitter vous êtes tout de
même l'auteur de petites formules qui
ont bien fonctionné des tweets très
repris et même un peu d'humour
on est donc allé chercher votre top 3
est ce que déjà vous avez une idée de ce
qui aurait pu bien fonctionné ce dont
vous êtes très fier ni non non non je ne
tiens pas depuis la vie politique et
la vie va trop vite pour j'ai le temps
de réfléchir à ça pourtant pendant la
can trois qui ont bien marché on va les
voir d'avoir le top 3 on est en avril
dernier jean pierre jouyet vient de
rejoindre l'elysée c'était avant la
sphère fillon en juillet et voilà ce que
vous écrivez sur twitter un ancien
ministre de sarkozy à l'elysée c'est la
monarchie de juillet depuis le 5 mai
dernier il y avait une marche citoyenne
organisée par le front de gauche et
voilà votre tweet tout en ironie si nous
étions trente mille a manifesté selon la
police aujourd'hui alors c'est que nous
avons défilé en file indienne
ironie aux 621 retweet en haut du podium
le meilleur on va le voir tout de suite
marine le pen n'est pas d'extrême droite
et moi je viens de prendre ma carte au
medef
en parlant de médailles d'ailleurs vous
êtes dit récemment prêt à débattre avec
pierre gattaz vous avez eu un échange
sur twitter à ce sujet et le patron du
medef vous a répondu sur twitter hier
ils vous proposent un débat dans
l'humanité vous répondez aussi sur
twitter banco pour un débat mais vous
voulez le faire aussi sur une chaîne
nationale pour l'instant il n'a pas
l'air très portrait va falloir le
convaincre oui on va s'en trouve à
s'employer à le convaincre et de toute
façon on mènera ce débat d'idées on
mènera ce débat d'idées jusqu'au bout 7
ans il organise mais juste je retiens
une il ya une critique en creux dans ce
qu'il dit est effectivement au mois je
j'ai en fait j'aime bien j'aime bien
l'humour et jeu j'aime bien alors si on
en quelques clics acerbe mais je le fais
pas assez mais aussi parce que j'ai un
certain respect de la parole publique
donc bon je fais attention avec ça mais
mon instinct
mais oui parce que c'est je ne jouais
pas respect de la parole publique j'ai
pas envie de d'alimenter un certain type
de débat public qui se contente que de
petites phrases
ceci étant dit à mes heures j'aime ça
aussi oui effectivement on se regroupe
pour tout l'été comme voulais faire
aussi sur public sénat le débat avec la
gata sur vous merci astrid
merci beaucoup alors merci à notre
émission on se retrouve bien évidemment
la semaine prochaine quatre heures sur
ce même plateau à la même heure merci à
tous de votre fidélité très bonne suite
de programmes sur lcp public sénat bye
bye